[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es das
letzte rezept aus meinem nudel monat ich
zeige euch die zubereitung für schnelle
nudeln mit einer tomatensoße mit zu
druck und schafskäse
ich habe die zutaten für dieses
nudelgericht eigentlich immer zu hause
denn ich liebe schafskäse und zu druck
darf auch nicht fehlen und deshalb zeige
ich euch jetzt direkt die zutaten
wir benötigen nun ist es egal welche
hinnimmt ich habe mich hier für penner
entschieden außerdem etwas gemüsebrühe
zwiebeln die habe ich bereits fein
gehackt und so druck den habe ich auch
klein geschnitten außerdem etwas schafs
oder hüttenkäse paprika mark und
tomatenmark an gewürzen pfeffer edel
süßes paprikapulver und oregano
zusätzlich noch etwas salz und ein wenig
öl
in einem hohen topf oder einer hohen
beschichteten pfanne geben wir jetzt die
zwiebeln mit zum öl und lassen sie
glasig dünsten
[Musik]
dann geben wir den schub mit hinzu und
lassen das so lange anbraten bis sie
durch sind
[Musik]
nun kommen tomaten und paprika marx
hinzu und werden ebenfalls mit
angeröstet wer kein paprika markt da hat
der kann die gleiche menge auch ganz
einfach durch tomatenmark ersetzen
jetzt wird alles mit der gemüsebrühe
abgelöscht und gibt da immer nach und
nach hinzu damit sich keine großen
kirchen bilden
sobald ihr dann unter ständigem rühren
die komplette gemüsebrühe mit dazu
gegeben habt könnt ihr das ganze einmal
aufkochen lassen
falls eure gemüsebrühe nicht ganz so
salzig es gibt ihr hier noch etwas extra
salz mit hinzu und auch die restlichen
gewürze
[Musik]
das besondere an diesem schnellen rezept
ist das für die nudeln jetzt direkt mit
dazu geben somit haben wir ein schnelles
landgericht
das heißt sobald das wasser einmal
aufgekocht ist gibt ihr die nudeln mit
hinzu rührt einmal um und gibt den
deckel drauf
die nudeln werden jetzt so lange gekocht
bis sie gar sind bei mir hat das circa
15 minuten gedauert und zwischendurch
habe ich immer wieder umgerührt damit am
topfboden auch nichts an klebt
[Musik]
wer keinen passenden deckel für seinen
topf da hat der kann auch ganz einfach
etwas mehr gemüsebrühe hinzufügen dann
verdampft es zwar schneller aber eure
nudeln werden dennoch gar
[Musik]
sobald die nudeln gar sind geben wir
dann noch den schafskäse mit hinzu und
der schmilzt dann noch in der rest hitze
[Musik]
das nudelgericht ist fertig und ihr
könnt es euch jetzt schmecken lassen wir
mögen es aber lieber mit etwas joghurt
hierfür nämlich am liebsten naturjoghurt
den fettarme und gäbe da klein gehackte
knoblauchzehen mit hinzu außerdem noch
etwas salz und dann vermenge ich das
ganze miteinander
obendrauf gebe ich dann noch etwas
getrocknete minze und reicht ihr das
dann zu den nudeln
diese nudeln sind perfekt für alle die
wenig zeit haben und trotzdem richtig
lecker mittagessen möchten
falls ihr auch lust habt dieser job
nudeln nachzumachen dann schaut mal
unten in der infobox dort stehen alle
genauen mengenangaben und ich freue mich
natürlich wie immer über fotos mit dem
hashtag s kitchen auf instagram
[Musik]
ich hoffe sehr dass euch der nudel monat
gefallen hat und ihr einiges nachgekocht
habt ich lasse mit definitiv mehrere
themen monate einfallen und informiert
euch dann natürlich wieder rechtzeitig
[Musik]
leute ich habe ganz vergessen euch zu
sagen die joghurt soße die gibt ihr ganz
einfach auf die nudeln drauf direkt
darüber würde ich die arme was drauf ich
glaube das handy auch gewusst was sagst
ja aber man muss es einmal demonstrieren
viel spaß beim nachbacken
[Musik]